[Musik]
auftakt zur schwierigen verhandlungen im
kanzleramt wird die libyen-konferenz
morgen intensiv vorbereitet
wieder protestieren tausende für die
zukunft der landwirtschaft diesmal gehen
bauern und klimaschützer gemeinsam für
eine agrarwende auf die straße nach 28
jahren wieder ein deutscher auf dem
podest thomas dreesen wird bei der
lauberhorn-abfahrt in wengen dritter
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute nachrichten im zdf diesmal mit
kristin otto die eine menge spaß dabei
richtig viel los guten abend seit dem
tod von machthaber gaddafi geht es in
libyen drunter und drüber
die unterschiedlichsten kräfte kämpfen
dort um macht und ressourcen
nun will die bundesregierung mit einer
großen libyenkonferenz morgen den
versuch starten die konflikt parteien an
einen tisch zu bekommen
libyen gilt als gescheiterter staat
seit jahren herrschen chaos und gewalt
für europa es lieben deswegen von
bedeutung weil es ein durchgangsland für
flüchtlinge ist und auch weil es mit
seinem gas und erdöl eine wichtige rolle
bei der energieversorgung spielt andreas
kühner ist berichtet als kanzlerin
merkel vor einer stunde die eu
kommissionschef in zum auto bringt hat
sie außerdem den kronprinz von abu dhabi
getroffen hat sie mit trump putin und
erdogan telefoniert hat sie libyen zu
ihrem thema gemacht
am tag vor merkels gipfel halten sie im
osten libyens in bengasi schilder mit
dem bild des dortigen machthabers hoch
dem abtrünnigen general haft und im
westen libyens in tripolis schilder auf
denen steht haft ist der bote des
teufels libyen gegen libyen eine
regierung in tripolis gegen eine in
bengasi eigentlich lehnen wir
verhandlungen wie in berlin ab aber da
unsere regierung nun mal beschlossen hat
teilzunehmen bitten wir darum unsere
perspektive zu sehen die jungen und
verwundeten und vertriebenen menschen
wenn die zwei verfeindeten anführer
libyens morgen in berlin sind kommt auf
politik polizei und hotels ein
aufreibender sonntag zu zuletzt sollen
sich premier savas und general hafttag
geweigert haben im selben raum zu sein
berichtet ein außenminister geschweige
denn sich zu treffen
das haffter seine anhänger gerade die
libyschen ölhäfen schließen lässt
belastet die konferenz zusätzlich das
ist eine botschaft an die welt wenn ihr
nicht zum libyschen volk steht wird das
libysche volk kein öl mehr exportieren
schon heute abend rollen im kanzleramt
spitzendiplomaten aus einem dutzend
länder vor um die erklärung der
staatschefs morgen vorzubereiten
mit einem waffenstillstand einem
einfuhrverbot von kriegswaffen und mit
reformen im bereich wirtschaft und
sicherheit schon fünfmal in den
vergangenen monaten haben sich die
teilnehmerstaaten heimlich in berlin
getroffen abwechselnd bei dem kanzleramt
mal im auswärtigen amt
das ergebnis dieser diskreten runden
lässt die bundesregierung optimistischer
sein als alle libyen vermittler zuvor in
washington bricht außenminister pompeo
nach berlin auf frieden in libyen
der nächste versuch wichtige konferenz
also morgen mit vielen gruppen die alle
verschiedene interessen in libyen haben
frage an uli gack unseren
korrespondenten für die region uli wenn
sich die großen strippenzieher
tatsächlich aus libyen zurückziehen
könnte dass das land befrieden
es würde zumindest mal die gegenwärtige
situation nicht weiter eskalieren das
problem ist dass immer mehr länder immer
mehr waffen an die konfliktparteien
bringen immer mehr söldner immer mehr
militärische geräte zur verfügung
stellen und diese spirale der gewalt
will man mit dieser berliner konferenz
und durchbrechen man will dahin kommen
dass man immer weniger immer weniger
waffen in die konfliktparteien stellt
und letztendlich zu dem waffenembargo
von 2011 zurückgekehrt man will dass
sich die einsicht durchsetzt dass dieser
grund fliegt wie militärisch zu gewinnen
ist dass es für alles unheimlich teuer
wird wenn sie diesen konflikt weiter
betreiben
dass dieses land letztendlich ein
geschundenes land ist das nach fast zehn
jahren immer noch keinen frieden
gefunden hat das misstrauen unterhalb
innerhalb dieser dieser ganzen
gruppierungen dieser unterstützer szene
ist enorm es sind bis auf iran alle die
versammelt die auch in syrien
gegeneinander kämpfen in herzlicher
feindschaft ob dieser dieser konferenz
morgen dieser einstieg in den ausstieg
der gewalt tatsächlich ein erfolg ist
das können wir heute noch längst nicht
sagen haft da wir haben es eben im
beitrag gehört hat die hand auf den
ölhäfen was verspricht er sich davon für
morgen naja wahrscheinlich weiteren
druck ausüben da will zeigen dass er das
starke mann ist in libyen dass er kurz
vor dem sieg ist das ohne ihn
letztendlich gar nichts geht vielleicht
ist es auch libyen ist das land der
stämme die schon immer untereinander
verfeindet waren vielleicht sind auch
die leute die mit denen er
zusammenarbeitet
im von der fahne gegangen kochen ihr
eigenes süppchen mit dem öl was
letztendlich genau dahinter steckt
wissen wir nicht aber es ist mit
sicherheit kein gutes omen für den
morgigen tag
herzlichen dank für ihre analyse juli
wichtige spannende konferenz morgen also
der kam vom libyens zukunft auf heute de
finden sie eine themenseite mit
hintergründen zu den machtpolitischen
interessen in dem bürgerkriegsland
wir haben es satt mit diesem slogan
demonstrieren heute tausende in berlin
für eine ökologische agrarwende
die forderung von mehr als 50 verbänden
aus bauern naturschützern und
verbrauchern ist einfach die
landwirtschaft soll sich nachhaltig
verändern
mehr umweltschutz mehr tierschutz mehr
rücksicht aufs klima vielen geht das zu
langsam obwohl sich der anteil des
ökologischen landbaus in den letzten 20
jahren fast vervierfacht hat
auf mehr als 9 prozent marcus groß
berlin ordentlich zu tun hat landwirt
jens petermann mit seinen 170 milchkühe
den betrieb hat er vor drei jahren auf
bio umgestellt das heißt mehr arbeit
mehr investitionen dafür haben seine
tiere jetzt auch mehr auslauf bekommen
eigenes öko futter
die derzeitige agrarpolitik die immer
stärker auf den globalen markt setzt
treibt ihn auf die straße
in dem moment wo ich eine überproduktion
zulasse weil ich globaler teilnehmer
werden möchte des marktes gehen die
preise damit gleich bleibend in die knie
und bei diesen niedrigen preisen kann
man einfach nicht mehr nachhaltig
produzieren wenn wir da nicht auf die
bremse treten wenn wir da nicht
zurückrudern ich denke denn wer bei
allem noch unser blaues wunder erleben
nicht blau sondern grüner soll die
landwirtschaft werden
tausende bauern klima und naturschützer
fordern dass heute fantasievoll ihr
protest mehr umwelt und naturschutz
steht villiger massenproduktion
klimakrise und das artensterben sind
dramatisch die bauern müssen
umweltgerecht produzieren müssen dafür
aber auch honoriert werden es muss sich
wieder lohnen klima gerecht und
umweltverträglich und tiergerecht zu
produzieren und die politik die
forderung endlich umzusteuern probleme
kann sagt die ministerin bei einem
spontanen auftritt ein weiter so mit den
vielen agrarsubventionen könne es nicht
geben heißt mehr geld für
umweltleistungen weniger gülle und
pestizide auf den feldern ein
umstrittenes thema vor allem bei vielen
konventionellen bauern öko landwirt
peter man sieht sich hingegen auf dem
richtigen weg er hat seine persönliche
agrarwende schon hinter sich
in einer veränderten welt fragt sich
auch die cdu wie weiter bei ihrer
vorstandsklausur hat die partei nun klar
gemacht dass auch sie sich verändern
muss zahlen bestätigen das beispiel
mitgliederschwund vor zehn jahren hatten
noch gut 521.000 ein cdu-parteibuch
vergangenes jahr nur noch rund 407.000
beispiel wahlverluste bei vielen
landtagswahlen in ost und west rutschten
die ergebnisse der christdemokraten
zuletzt in den keller
mathis feldhoff
wahlkampfauftritt kurz nach der
klausurtagung beim kinderchor der
malteser doch das klima für die cdu in
hamburg ist so frostig wie die
temperaturen
vor 15 jahren war man noch stärkste
kraft jetzt nur noch platz drei
exemplarisch für das großstadtproblem
der cdu die vorsitzende wäre schon
zufrieden wenn es zur
regierungsbeteiligung reicht zur not als
junger partner wenn rot grün hier nicht
die richtigen antworten für die zukunft
gibt dann ist es am ende egal wer in
einer solchen mischung die nase vorne
hat überraschend ein vorstoß zur
verkleinerung des bundestages seit
monaten diskutieren die
bundestagsparteien
die cdu kann sich jetzt offenbar
vorstellen auf zehn prozent der 299
wahlkreise zu verzichten ist es am
morgen aus der cdu spitze
nach heftigen protesten der csu die um
ihre direktmandate fürchtet unterließ
die cdu vorsitzende aber eine
öffentliche festlegung zurückhaltung
auch bei der eu forderung nach einer
militärmissionen libyen aber nein hat
sie dann auch nicht gesagt wenn es
gelingt dass dort wirklich
waffenstillstand nachhaltig vereinbart
werden kann
dann wird natürlich auch die frage
kommen wie soll das geschehen wer soll
absichert keine debatten diesmal über
personal nicht zur kanzlerkandidatur
nicht zu einer kabinettsumbildung zur
freude der wahl kämpfen die menschen
draußen weil wir brauchen nicht
verunsicherungen und die brauchen mich
neue thesen und theorien die dann
sowieso nicht antreten
kramp karrenbauer hat ihrer partei
sacharbeit verordnet dazu gehört auch
ein neues programm das sind frühjahr
vorliegen sollten
auch die csu führt das christliche im
namen
da fällt es teilen der basis schwer mit
einem muslimischen
bürgermeisterkandidaten am 15 märz in
die kommunalwahl zu gehen so im
schwäbischen wallertheim wo ein
muslimischer kandidat wegen seines
glaubens abgelehnt wurde
zum ärger der csu führung anders im
oberbayerischen neufahrn wo ein muslim
alevitischen glaubensrichtung einstimmig
gewählt wurde
patricia schäfer besser geht's nicht mit
100 prozent der stimmen nominierte die
csu sei nie was als
bürgermeisterkandidatin oberbayerischen
neu fahren
ich bin überwältigt von dem ergebnis und
ich freue mich dass die mitglieder der
ortsvorstand aber auch die
gemeindebürger hinter mir stehen
neufahrn ist eine 20.000 einwohner
gemeinde nördlich von münchen
zuletzt stellte die csu hier vor mehr
als 30 jahren den bürgermeister
nun will die partei das amt zurück
gewinnen mit ihrem ersten muslimischen
bürgermeisterkandidaten der 37 jährige
unternehmensberater i was ist hier
geboren und aufgewachsen hat türkische
wurzeln und ist alle wied also liberaler
muslim teils finde es in ordnung teils
denke ich warum haben wir keine von
unserem eigenen reihen
auch vertreter der csu parteispitze sind
nach neuwahlen gekommen und stärken ihm
den rücken
susanne pesch ist hier neu war ein
toller kandidat dasteht war alles was
die csu ausmacht er ist hier verwurzelt
vor ort er ist ein bilderbuch bayern
was sagt er teile das christliche
menschenbild und benutzt ganz
selbstverständlich eine bayerisch
katholische dankes vorne
ein herzliches vergelt's gott an den
ortsverband und an meine gemeinde neu
waren die mich nicht auf meine herkunft
reduzieren sondern die den eigentlichen
menschen lieber scannen achten und
schätzen in zwei monaten bei den
bayerischen kommunalwahlen wird sich
zeigen ob das der erste muslimische
bürgermeister der csu wird die
pannenserie bei boeing reißt nicht ab
wieder gibt es probleme mit dem
unglücksflieger
737 max der konzern teilte mit man habe
einen neuen software fehler entdeckt
seit vergangenem märz müssen die 737 max
flugzeuge am boden bleiben
bei zwei abstürzen waren insgesamt 346
menschen ums leben gekommen
auch dabei soll defekte software eine
rolle gespielt haben
die neuen probleme könnten die
wiederzulassung der maschinen weiter
verzögern
seit monaten brennen große teile
australiens und nichts haben die
menschen dort mehr herbeigesehnt als
regen
der ist nun da und es zeigt sich dass zu
viel des guten auch schlecht ist nach
dem feuer wänden bedrohen jetzt
flutwellen mensch und tier ein ganzer
kontinent im griff der naturgewalten
florian krotzek berichtet endlich wasser
ich war noch nie so nah an einem koala
sagt der junge eigentlich halten sich
die tiere fern von menschen doch dieser
koala scheint seine scheu vergessen zu
haben
zu groß seien du hast so lange hatten
tier und mensch unter hitze und
trockenheit gelitten jetzt freude über
das lang ersehnte nass
es ist einfach schön das prasseln auf
dem dach zu hören es ist lange her dass
wir das hatten also genießen wir es
monatelang kein regen und nun gleich so
viel zu viel
die ausgedörrten knochenharten böden
können all das wasser nicht aufnehmen
mancherorts steht es meter hoch ein
tierpark nördlich von sydney muss
evakuiert werden noch vor einer woche
herrschte hier angst vor den
herannahenden flammen jetzt die flucht
vor den wassermassen
koalas klammern sich an ihre pfleger
krokodile versuchen auszubrechen mit
einem besen können wörter sie
zurückhaltend
auf facebook gibt es inzwischen
entwarnung alle tiere sind in sicherheit
und der park genießt den dringend
benötigten regen
trotz der umstände weiter südlich
kämpfen die einsatzkräfte noch immer
gegen dutzende brände ein paar kleine
feuer konnte der regen löschen doch
gegen die großen hat er keine chance
trotzdem hilft er dabei die flammen
etwas einzudämmen und verschafft den
feuerwehrleuten wenigstens eine kleine
atempause
mit viel schnee hat dagegen der osten
kanadas zu kämpfen mehrere stürme zogen
in der nacht übers land
insane johns an der ostküste und anderen
städten wurde der notstand ausgerufen
stromausfälle und verschneite straßen
auch hier eine eiskalte überraschung
erlebte dieser mann als er das
garagentor öffnen wollte der ausgang war
versperrt durch eine rand aus schnee
wahnsinnsbilder fehlt wintersport gab es
heute nach der handball und vor allem
auch rollt der fußball wieder an genau
die rückrunde ist los gegangen in der
bundesliga gladbach hat er die chance
verpasst vorläufig neuer spitzenreiter
zu werden
große freude dagegen bei borussia
dortmund dank des überragenden
neuzugangs jährigen harlan erzielt bei
seinem debüt gleich drei treffer für den
bvb 5 3 in augsburg frust in hoffenheim
erleichterungen bei frankfurt 12
erstmalig in der bundesliga geschichte
gegen freiburg in mainz zwei zu eins
köln wolfsburg 3 1 bremen 1 0 im
kellerduell bei düsseldorf alles zum
abend spielen mit tabellenführer eher
beleibt sich gegen union berlin
ausführlich im aktuellen sportstudio
gestern schalkes 2 zu 0 gegen gladbach
morgen die bayern in berlin sowie
leverkusen in paderborn in der tabelle
können die leipziger jetzt ihre
spitzenposition ausbauen und die bayern
morgen an gladbach vorbeiziehen
dortmund und schalke bleiben punktgleich
dran freiburg schiebt sich vor
leverkusen und hoffenheim in der unteren
hälfte frankfurt hoch auf 11 köln auf 13
bremen nun auf dem relegationsplatz vor
düsseldorf und schlusslicht paderborn
und zu gast im aktuellen sportstudio
heute bereits von 22.15 an freiburgs
erfolgstrainer christian streich direkt
nach dem zweiten hauptrundenspiel der
deutschen handballer bei der
europameisterschaft gegen kroatien
hier sehen wir die mannschaft von
bundestrainer christian prokop bei der
ankunft in der halle von wien in 75
minuten beginnt der showdown gegen die
kroaten ein sogenanntes schlüsselspiel
denn yorck polus mit blick auf das
halbfinale zählt nur ein sieg
kerstin das ist ganz richtig wenn der
traum vom halbfinale weiter gehen soll
dann muss die deutsche mannschaft sogar
gleich alle vier hauptrunden spiele
gewinnen aber klar ist auch der heutige
gegner kroatien ist mit abstand
stärksten einzuschätzen aber die
deutsche mannschaft weiß auch im
vergleich zum vergangenen zum letzten
spiel gegen weissrussland ist eine
deutliche leistungssteigerung her aber
dann könnte der traum vom halbfinale
weitergehen und 20 uhr fünfter jetzt
ernst hier in der wiener stadthalle
wirklich da und wir sind dabei york
vielen dank erfolgreicher weltcup tag
für den deutschen bobsports bei starkem
schneefall in innsbruck igls triumphiert
zunächst olympiasiegerin maria naja man
kann mit annika tratzig vor der deutsche
meisterin laura nolte und danach fährt
rekord weltmeister francesco friedrich
mit torsten marx im zweier der herren
auch bestzeit zudem em silber im rodeln
in lillehammer für julia taubitz hinter
der russin tatjana iwanowa und es gab
noch mehr highlights im schnee thomas
christen aus mittenwald fährt bei der
legendären lauberhorn abfahrt auf den
dritten platz
zum besten deutschen ergebnis seit 28
jahren schnellsten wengen der schweizer
wertvoll
vierschanzentournee sieger david
kubatzki aus polen gewinnt das
skispringen in titisee-neustadt beste
deutsche stephan leyhe und constantin
schmid auf einem geteilten fünften platz
snowboarderin ramona hoffmeister im
hellen trikot wird beim parallel
riesenslalom in slowenien nach zuletzt
vier einzelerfolgen zweite geschlagen
nur von der tschechischen
olympiasiegerin sdax gab und noch mehr
natürlich im netz unter zdf sport.de und
live morgen von 10 uhr 15 an
viel los danke christin ja im norden
sonnig sonst eher stärker bewölkt und
schauer gibt es gemischt mit schnee so
wird unser sonntagswetter die
einzelheiten gleich von katja honnefer
das war es von uns danke für ihr
interesse
christian sievers und das heute journal
heute schon um fünf nach 9
in der handball pause uns gibt es morgen
wieder punkt 19 uhr einen schönen
sonntag und tschüss
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren nach
dem tief heike kommt sofort das hocheck
art nach interessantes aber tief ilka
denn in den nächsten tagen bringt das
sehr ungemütliches wetter über der
iberischen halbinsel
da ist regen dabei schnee nicht nur in
den pyrenäen und viel wind der schnee
der heute in den alpen fiel und am
alpenrand der wahl wahrscheinlich höchst
willkommen das waren so 10 bis 20
zentimeter neuschnee und soviel kann
auch morgen noch einmal zusammenkommen
über österreich war die wolkendecke
dicht arbeiten bei der schweiz erkennen
sie sehr gut die schneefreien täler und
oberhalb von etwa 1000 meter die
schneebedeckten gipfel auch jetzt in der
nacht schneit es am alpenrand noch
weiter es gibt einige schauer im
nordwesten auf glatte straßen müssen sie
sich allerdings eigentlich überall
gefasst machen denn bei lufttemperaturen
zwischen 3 grad in husum und minus vier
grad in oberstdorf ist es überall kalt
genug für bodenfrost einzige ausnahme
die ostfriesischen inseln morgen liegen
die temperaturen zwischen minus ein grad
über schnee am alpenrand und 8 grad im
nordwesten und besonders an der see wird
das morgen ein sehr sonniger sonntag bei
billigen nordwind der treibt die schauer
zum beispiel als erzgebirge oder auch im
sauerland und am alpenrand schneit es
länger weiter die neue woche startet
deutlich ruhiger schönen abend noch